Well,
partly
this is what I know and I,
it's something,
you know,
when I was in my early twenties,
I was writing all sorts of stories and I
wrote a few of these stories about these
sort of guys.
Um,
and an editor,
a editor named Josh Glenn,
who was the editor of Herman,
ah,
um,
you know,
in these stories,
they're not in the book.
They didn't make it into the book.
They weren't very good and he said,
you know,
um,
but he read the stories and he didn't
take them for Herman Monotony,
didn't publish them,
but he said,
you should keep doing this.
This is,
I don't know anyone who knows these
people the way you do.
Um,
and I was surprised to hear that because
I thought everybody knew these people
the way I did.
Um,
and,
you know,
and in a way everybody does.
Um,
and yet there's actually surprisingly
little writing about them.
Um,
and one of the really
a,
to me,
not terribly surprising but still
disappointing criticism of the book has
been,
well,
why do we need to hear about these guys?
We all know guys just like them,
right?
Which strikes me is,
is,
uh,
an invalid form of literary criticism,
but also strikes me as a refusal of a
certain kind of person to admit that
they belong to a social class.
So,
um,
you know,
you're willing.
So these are people who,
um,
and often this sort of criticism comes
from New York.
It's a kind of provincial criticism,
um,
from people who believe that their own
little world is not worthy of depiction
and literature.
Uh,
whereas first of all,
you know,
it's not just New York with either a
young literary men all over the country
and in other countries.
Um,
and so it's,
it's a mistake and the provincial
mistake,
the fact that they're only in New York,
um,
but more than that,
uh,
you know,
this is actually something that invades,
if talks about the intelligentsia,
right or in,
in,
in the US,
this literary the sad young literary men
and women,
uh,
they form a social class and uh,
they have to admit that to themselves
because while they are willing to a be a
social class in terms of using their,
uh,
their privilege,
um,
uh,
their,
their w,
if they have money,
they're in their class and their money
privileged,
uh,
their access to various media,
which is a form of privilege.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
uh,
the,
all the various networks that they have
access to from the colleges that they
went to.
Um,
somehow they refuse to believe that
there are social class,
um,
that ought to be depicted in literature.
Um,
except I,
except,
unless it's totally ironic,
right?
Um,
and you know,
they do,
and this is,
this is where hipster culture comes
from,
right?
So we have a hipster culture that,
that in a way acknowledges that it
exists as a class and yet only
ironically,
right?
I'm only,
uh,
and you know,
one of the least,
one of the most unattractive things
about the hipster phenomenon is it's a,
is it's classing down,
right?
It's,
its insistence on,
on this form of kitsch.
Were they,
they were a trucker hats,
no trucker hats,
right?
Where they pretend to be from a
different social class.
Right?
Um,
this is a very good example of this
group of people refusing to acknowledge,
um,
their,
their class privilege,
um,
and,
you know,
so to get back to the book,
the Saturn Larry men or social class A,
they ought to be written about,
they have to be studied.
Um,
and I don't,
unsurprisingly,
a,
you would think everybody would be
writing about them because we're all in
it.
Um,
and surprisingly little seems to be
written about it.
Uh,
and I think,
you know,
I also think,
um,
I also hope that the book is,
is,
is pretty honest about the way these
people behave.
Um,
and how badly they behave.
I think we have a fair amount of
literature that is,
that deals with the men behaving badly,
uh,
but the men are often depicted as total
cats,
a total lo lifes,
total losers.
I'm,
these guys are more complicated than
that,
you know,
um,
they are capable of being very sweet
and,
uh,
and sort of supportive and nice.
And then also not so nice.